fans of director zack snyder's vision of
the dceu
can finally watch zack snyder's justice
league but that doesn't mean all of our
questions are answered
not long after he emerges in themyscira
steppenwolf was contacted by dasar
regarding his progress in conquering
earth during their exchange we learned
that steppenwolf is not darkseid's
favorite guy right now
steppenwolfer begs for the chance to
return home once he conquers earth
a plea desade reacts to with anger he
says steppenwolf's self-pride made him
betray darkseid and this is why he still
owes the ruler 50 000 worlds before he
can return home
as for the betrayal dasar is talking
about the most obvious answer is that
steppenwolf was part of a rebellion
against darkseid
and perhaps was even its leader this
seems to be the case
since steppenwolf defends himself to
desaad by saying he saw his mistake and
slaughtered those who sought his throne
it would also accurately reflect the
villain's relationship in the source
material
but it's never explicitly stated what
happened and considering what we know
about darkseid the notion that
steppenwolf or anyone else could be a
part of a failed rebellion against him
and survive the experience
is nothing short of miraculous it's also
worth noting that steppenwolf is nowhere
to be seen in the flashback of
darkseid's first attempt to conquer
earth could it be that darkseid blames
steppenwolf at least in part for
something he did that contributed to the
dark tyrant's defeat so many years ago
after reporting to the sab that he's
discovered the anti-life equation on
earth steppenwolf is shocked to be
contacted by darkseid himself
while it's clear steppenwolf still needs
to conquer earth before darkseid is
willing to bring him back to his inner
circle
the very fact that he decides to speak
to steppenwolf is a clear sign that
darkseid's view of him has improved at
least a little bit
but what's confusing is the fact that
the location of the anti-life equation
needs to be rediscovered we see darkseid
finding it in the flashback to his first
unsuccessful battle
against the combined forces of earth
we're also told his defeat on earth was
the first and likely only such lust
yet when steppenwolf discovers the
anti-life equation we're told darkseid
had lost the location of the world
but how could he with all of his
advanced technology lose its location
one possibility is that it would have
been revealed that this was a side
effect of the dceu version of the
anti-life equation
that to discover it and not immediately
possess it would obscure the minds and
technology of those who found it
there are a lot of hints dropped in zack
snyder's justice league that lois lane
is expecting superman's baby
including a shot of a pregnancy test in
her apartment while the film doesn't
offer a definitive answer the director
himself has chimed in
in a march 2021 interview with esquire
zack snyder confirmed lois lane is
definitely pregnant
and that isn't all he said having
superman's child isn't raring
contemporary media
he has a super powered son in the comics
in 2006's superman returns he has a son
who is eventually revealed to have
powers while the cwu's crisis on
infinite earth's crossover reveals tyler
heckland superman has twins the superman
and lowest series shows us the boys in
high school
with one of them showing signs of
increased abilities though not exactly
on par with the man of steel
what snyder told esquire is very
different first of all the director said
lois and clark's suspected child is a
boy and he would have no powers
second he revealed that his long-term
plan was that ben affleck's batman would
eventually sacrifice himself and that's
under the mentorship of barbara gordon
the child of superman would become the
next batman
because of his march 2021 interview with
esquire
we know zack snyder actually planned a
scene with the green lantern jon stewart
for justice league and
almost quit over the question of
including it but while stuart doesn't
show up in zack snyder's justice league
we do get brief appearances from two
other green lanterns
in the flashback to the past we see the
obscure lantern jarlinger
joining the forces of earth against
darkseid unfortunately he
doesn't last long against the tyrant and
is brutally killed
later in one of the post-apocalyptic
nightmare shots we see the corpse of
killerwork
one of the more well-known alien members
of the green lantern corps
but we're still left with a very big
question of why the green lantern corps
isn't getting itself involved with
steppenwolf's attempt to take over the
earth drawing the present storyline of
zack snyder's justice league
the world's most powerful champion
superman is dead for most of the film
and the conquering of the world would
mean not only the deaths of millions if
not billions of humans but darkseid
finally claiming the anti-life equation
this would seem worthy of sending at
least
one or two core members to support the
justice league with snyder's plans
changed we're left to only speculate
shortly after the person who appears to
be martha kent visits lowest lane in
metropolis we learn that it's in fact
jon jones
also known as the martian manhunter fans
had long theorized that harry lennox's
general swanwick
introduced in 2013's man of steel was
the martian survivor in disguise
and zack snyder's justice league
confirms it we have legitimate security
concerns
but in light of the rest of the film we
have to wonder whether or not lois lane
will ever discover that she was visited
by the martian manhunter
at the very least it seems likely she
would eventually learn she was visited
by someone who wasn't martha kent
after all martha is reunited with lois
and her son toward the end of the film
in kansas
it seems likely that's not realising
that superman would eventually be
resurrected martian manhunter assumed
lois lane and martha kent wouldn't be
speaking to each other any time soon
it also makes us wonder if in light of
his reveal at the end of the film
jones will fess up to his deception so
as to not cause lois and the kens to
freak out without reason
after visiting lois lane martian
manhunter's time in zack snyder's
justice league isn't over
at the end of the film he visits bruce
wayne hoping to be of service in any
future crises which begs the question of
exactly
why it takes him so long to reveal
himself the earth certainly could have
used him to do more than give lois lane
a pep talk
if this martian manhunter is meant to be
anything like his comic book counterpart
he'd be one of the most powerful members
of the team
if not the most powerful his abilities
in the source material
include super strength flight heat
vision shape-shifting
and telepathy it could be that 2016's
batman vs superman dawn of justice
tells us why the hero waited so long
martian manhunter
likely saw the arrival of superman as
something of a litmus test for how earth
would react to the presence of a
powerful alien being
and in dawn of justice the reaction is
that one of earth's heroes challenges
that being to a fight
and tries to kill them the manhunter
from mars probably took the events of
dawn of justice as a sign that it was a
good idea to keep to the shadows
strong man as strong as alone you ever
heard that
right before the final nightmare
sequence zack snyder's justice league
gives us a new version of the meetup
between lex luthor and deathstroke
rather than talking about forming a team
to counter the justice league
lex reveals batman's secret identity to
slade wilson
this was likely meant to lead into the
original plans for the batman when ben
affleck was still attached to the lead
but there's a larger question of what
exactly lex is up to here
is this just his way of disrupting
things for batman or does he think in
spite of the dark knight nearly killing
superman and dawn of justice
that death joke has what it takes to
kill him or is he playing a longer game
here
does he perhaps have longer term plans
to form an injustice league
and is simply using this moment to earn
deathstroke's trust we may never know
unfortunately
we first see batman's versions of a
world fallen to dark sides armies in
batman vs superman
dawn of justice the end of zack snyder's
justice league gives us another vision
this new nightmare begins with batman
and a small band of rebels hiding from
darkseid's parademons
and ends with the arrival of a hostile
superman whilst it isn't clear however
it's exactly water who is sending batman
these visions
not to mention the vision cyborg
experiences they seem far
too specific to simply be random
considering the mysterious arrival and
disappearance of the flashing dawn of
justice
right after batman's first nightmare and
the fact that the flash of the dceu is
capable of time travel there's a good
chance that time travel is at work here
the fact that joker mentions alternate
timelines in his conversation with
batman
points to this as well but that still
doesn't explain why wayne receives these
visions
in batman's nightmare vision it's clear
that the future has gotten bad enough
that former enemies are now allies
along with justice league teammates
flash and cyborg batman is joined by the
atlantean
mirror the mercenary deathstroke and his
arch nemesis
the joker as joker taunts batman with
memories of those he's lost
joker makes it clear he doesn't take any
of batman's threats seriously
he tells the dark knight that he needs
the joker to undo the world of batman
made it's a mystery what joker means
here without any superpowers of his own
joker wouldn't necessarily seem to be
the key to any kind of battle with
darkseid or a dark side controlled
superman
it could be that the heroes simply need
anyone with any kind of combat prowess
along for the ride
and a gotham villain capable of going
one-on-one with batman
fits the bell but particularly with
joker's mention of alternate timelines
he seems to be pointing towards
something more specific
one clue could be joker mentioning that
batman made this world by letting lois
lane die
could it be that joker murdered lois and
that they need the clown to somehow undo
this via time travel
whatever the answer is considering
joker's words and the presence of the
flash
we think it's a sure bet time travel is
involved
after joker's done taunting batman bruce
responds by revealing that harley quinn
died in his arms
and that supposedly her last words were
a plea that batman make joker's death a
slow one
joker responds oh you're good you almost
had me assuming batman is telling the
truth we have to wonder how harley quinn
died
considering the state the world is in
it's obvious that plenty of superheroes
and villains
have died fighting darkseid and his
armies from the various nightmare
visions in the film
we know wonder woman and killer work
have died there's a decent chance harley
quinn is another victim of this war
either as part of the suicide squad or
otherwise allied with earth's defenders
if batman's telling the truth that is
zack snyder's justice league hints at so
many more promising directions in which
schneider wanted to bring the story of
dc's most iconic heroes
darkseid seems intent on invading the
earth at the end of the film
lex luthor has his own plans and martian
manhunter is ready to join the league
for now it seems that zack snyder's
justice league served as a triumphant
conclusion to the so-called snyderverse
speaking to variety in march 2021 warner
media studios ceo
and sonoff made it clear that the plan
moving forward is to say goodbye to
snyder's cinematic universe
you'll have to give me a little time to
confirm we don't have any more time
but who knows probably everyone but the
fans campaigning for the snyder curse
likely never expected zack snyder's
justice league to ever be released and
yet here it is we're willing to bet that
at the very least some of the same fans
are ready to start campaigning
one more time check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about the dc
extended universe are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell
so you don't miss a single one